alors à notamment une chanson qui
s'appelle halimi je cherche un alibi
pour éliminer ton mec qui te trompe je
la kiffe ça la jolie jackie brown c'est
vrai que est-ce que vous avez déjà servi
d'alibi peut-être servi d'alibi toi une
copine ou un copain
pourquoi pour faire des bêtises huawei
ah non mais jamais de la vie moi je suis
en tissage genre ma copine avait trompé
de couvin limites et c'est moi je dis va
te balancer tout seul non c'est vrai
away jacques c'est à venir ici tacopina
depuis je trouve mes copains tu appelles
direction comme toi mais je trouve ça un
truc de la fois je suis en fait c'est
même plus ma copine en fait celle fait
sa ba voilà bah beinheim toi ah oui on
sort de la grèce notamment la grèce
on sait ce que tu fais mais là il bat
les jo de caunes est allé à l'époque des
capétiens
non ça y est vous vous avez servi
d'alibi lekhwiya n'a même plus les fois
très souvent pourquoi on dit quoi et
donc chaque fois je sais mais chaque
fois je disais imagine que tu rentres
chez toi et tu trouves tu arrêtes ta
copine au lit ça te fait quoi on parle
pas d'une dépanneuse horreurs comme ça
tant qu en fait il ya beaucoup de mes
fidèles juste parce qu'ils sont trop
sûrs de leur femme c'était que d'être
nourri les filles il faut l'inquiétude
c'est le meilleur ciment du couple
d'accord mais là vous n'avez pas eu
plein d'idées qui supporte pas
et on sait pas ce que tu as boulonnais
en fait c'est bhl exemple javert des
chefs me dit tu peux dire à ma femme que
tu peux tu dire à ma femme que je pars
en angleterre je lui ça me paraît loin
tu peux pas faire un mensonge plus
modestes parce que si jamais elle vient
dans le quartier qu'elle se trouve au
nord elle vient jamais dans le quartier
que sa femme des prix mais une copine
lui dis tiens tu viens on va faire les
antiquaires de la rue bonaparte
non j'aime bien sûr l'autre non et avec
sa copine moi comme une conne là est la
femme qui a vraiment vraiment pas
apprécié du tout abattu la firme assure
la méchante ans bien sûr c'est vrai à la
réserve voit en tout cas merci
évidemment attendu puisque on devait
réveiller oui oui oui
moi j'ai eu pire chez servi une fois
d'albi cette dernière alors qu à ça
alors toi juste vous savez comment se
sert d'alibi avec lui oui lui se cache
directement sous le nom c'est le seul
gars en train de mai fut des raisons qui
sont sur le lien il attend les titres
wii alors oui non non non non c'est un
copain qui me dit tu dis je suis avec
toi il allait voir sa maîtresse ouais
bon je dois quitter le poste à un
classique seulement il a eu un problème
avec la maîtresse au lit c'est à dire
qu'il a eu ce qu'on appelle une verge
brisé un verre je brise est ce qu'on
appelle une vb bbc min
aux métiers comme ça nous fait envie
d'acheter une femme jane valbuena ménagé
une mathieu valbuena oui alors oui et
non mais ça arrive et on en est
il a cassé son jouet aurait donc il
vient me voir et donc je l'emmène à
l'hôpital et tout ça et après on va les
voir ma femme
commenta univers je brisais chez moi
j'ai dit c'est quand même compliqué à
expliquer c'est le corps spongieux qui
s'est pliée
c'est intéressant ça arrive quand on
regarde sa partenaire et qu'on veut la
retourner c'est bon c'est quoi la faune
histoire la presse et d'expliquer et le
gars comme ils l'ont dit c'est pour le
braquer casser non c'est juste
ils ont placardé vous avez signé sur ce
vote mais non c'est pas un os ah ouais
bah oui c'est un corps spongieux
ouais c'est ça se reforme il faut masser
et que cette arrivée à l'hôpital j'ai
dit quoi ben ils ont ils ont élus ont
soigné leur fait une piqûre ça fait très
mal
alors je suis en l'état la prévoir sa
femme on a dit qu'il avait porté une
caisse une caisse
[Rires]
j'écoute tu vas pas me croire et qu'au
dessus comme ça on est à travers les
emplettes à quatre premiers bulletins on
va faire un délire je vais le mettre sur
mon disque d'alençon ont saisi là mais
c'est à dire sa femme alors je sais pas
si elle a cru enfin la côte est comme ça
le mensonge mais je pense qu'il a dû
avoir une drôle d'explication une fois
que j'étais parti hadatha bien d'accord
ayad hôtelier à d'autres genres à
bernard montiel non non non non tu es
j'ai souvent servi d'alibi va tout comme
tu dis non non non juste des patrons en
parler non mais souvent parce que comme
je vis seul donc souvent dit cheikh
bernard voilà est en fait pas du tout
voilà c'est pas compliqué c'est à dire
est ce que c'est ça pour une histoire
mais c'est tout vous avez été si vous
faites ça rien de libye si on vous
demande maintenant il est à mon copain
début le sucre choix alors moi je vous
dire chacun sa merde
ben ali n'ont en effet jamais personne
me demande avant bizarrement embrasé
nous parlait trop peut-être mon agent
m'a dit vous savez que gardez-vous
agréablement des sabres c'est marrant le
langage corporel vous baissez les yeux
commenté c'est quoi alors je vire les
gens si je vote
[Applaudissements]